les vacances présidentielles arrivée
très attendue cet après-midi à louxor du
nouveau couple le plus traqué par les
paparazzi
le président français nicolas sarkozy et
la chanteuse carla bruni se sont pour la
première fois affiché main dans la main
à l'entrée du palace au new venture en
hôtel victoria situé en bordure du nil
ils ont ensuite effectué une promenade
le long du fleuve suivie par une armada
de photographes et de badauds sur place
le reportage de franck gêne au zoo et
ahmed salah main dans la main sur la
corniche de louxor ils profitent de la
nuit qui tombe sur le nul nicolas
sarkozy l'ex mannequin carla bruni ne
cachent plus leur idylle
escorté par de nombreux policiers en
civil quelques clichés offert aux
photographes puis les paparazzi sont
vite prié d'aller voir ailleurs
épilogue d'un après midi agitée dans la
cité égyptienne quelques heures plus tôt
très peu de photographes à l'arrivée du
convoi présidentiel
et pour cause une rumeur annoncé le
président à l'autre bout de la ville
ceux qui ne sont pas tombés dans le
piège ont eu la photo du jour ils se
tiennent la main explique celui ci
elle est là l'histoire c'est pour ça que
j'étais venu un petit geste en direction
des badauds puis le couple disparaît
sous l'oeil de touristes français
partagés parce que
milliards donc si l'euro elle est
heureuse qui font pas ça pour quoi la
publicité avec sa vue imprenable sur le
nil ces jardins exotiques et sa piscine
lol winter palace accueillera les
invités du président durant trois jours
en moyenne 500 euros la nuit par chambre
l'entourage présidentiel en aurait
réservé une vingtaine selon certains
responsables locaux la délégation
devrait se rendre aux célèbres temples
de karnak où il pourrait croiser
l'ancien premier ministre tony blair lui
aussi annoncé sur les bords du nil
le temple de louxor ou encore la tombe
de néfertari nicolas sarkozy voulait
tant voyage discret mais il fait prévu
un agenda chargé
il devra encore composer avec la
présence des paparazzi